you don't know everything about me
The Avengers weren't my first family at
some point we all have to choose between
what the world wants you to be
new you are how's it going everybody
it's Warren and we just got a brand new
Super Bowl TV spot with new footage for
the Black Widow movie coming out in May
so it's only 30 seconds but we actually
have quite a bit of new footage most of
the footage was actually new and this TV
spot it's all about her previous family
before the Avengers she starts off by
saying you don't know everything about
me the Avengers weren't my first family
now obviously she is talking about Red
Guardian Yelina Bulova and Avelina vasta
cough now the question here is who
exactly is she talking to we don't know
who she's talking to when she says you
don't know everything about me she could
be talking to Thunderbolt Ross but it's
also very possible that she could be
talking to Tony Stark because remember
this takes place right after Civil War
where she's on the run she helped out
technically the wrong aside so to say as
far as the government is concerned she's
a fugitive but we know that Tony Stark
is going to be in the movie so it's most
likely him going to talk to her to try
and turn herself in we get a new shot of
red Guardian here it looks like he's
busting out of the prison that he's been
in and they were here Natasha's say at
some point we have to choose between
what the world wants you to be and who
you are and here we get very briefly a
lot of new footage we see Black Widow
Yelena Bulova milena Vostok off and red
Guardian all together and it looks like
they just accomplished a mission
together so this could very well be set
in the past before she went off and
joined the Avengers and as you can see
here they all look like a family they're
all holding hands and red Guardian has
his arm around Malina basta cough that
kind of further proves the rumor that
Malina and red Guardian are going to be
married in this movie and then of course
we get taskmaster we have some more
fight scenes between the two of them a
lot of other action scenes as well and
then we see an awesome scene of
taskmaster pulling his shield back on
his arm it looks like it's actually some
type of magnetic technology it looks
absolutely insane and that makes
taskmaster even more deadly because not
only can he throw his shield but he can
retract it as well the TV spot ends with
Black Widow saying sometimes you have to
choose who you are and it shows a
picture of her and Jelena Bulova and
that's most likely them trying to take
down the Black Widow program and that's
it for this TV spot it was only 30
seconds long but we got a ton of new
footage in it let me know
you think about it and let me know how
excited you are to see Black Widow when
it comes out on May 1st don't forget to
subscribe for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 like the video and comment
down below as well as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof